[Music]  you guys are the Fab five we want to  play a fast five with you we do it the  et Fast Five so you guys have that  amazing truck who's last to get in the  truck who takes the longest out of them  who is the last to get in that truck  when you guys get Jonathan you guys have  a little cocktail when you watch the  footage of the show who drinks the most  said who controls the second is the boss  on set Bobby we all have to vent who  vents the most me and you know I sobbed  watching season when I watched it like  all day on a Saturday and really lost  myself there who of you guys cries the  most unsafe Rosie yeah especially my  guard is down and I can give a good snot  cry yeah okay and who cries the most you  and answer you're tied yeah